bonjour monsieur simple contrôle
anti-pollution vous laissez le moteur
allumé nous allons vous mettre une sonde
dans le pot d'accord
1740 1740
mais je fais pas une immobilisation je
fais une réquisition du véhicule
c'est une immobilisation pour pollution
mais pas
et vous la récupérez dans quoi dans une
petite semaine
j'habite pas loin j'habite à Colombes ah
bah voilà comme ça vous pouvez rentrer à
pied
[Musique]
tu es obligé de réquisitionner le
véhicule monsieur
c'est vous qui avez un rendez-vous à ma
place ou quoi là genre tout de suite la
pastille la voiture la moins d'un an du
genre il faut une passible sur la
voiture et que c'est la dernière minute
qu'on nous demande ça et vous êtes tous
les deux là comme ça genre tous les deux
vous allez bloquer la voiture vous
croyez quoi moi franchement je m'arrache
attendez monsieur
moi je veux pas perdre de temps moi
vous faites un peu vite je m'arrache
hein c'est parce que j'attendais là
justement je viens de recevoir le
message le portable le portable c'est ça
alors les papiers
c'est ça on l'a dit les portables on en
reparle OK
[Musique]
voilà je me suis fait gauler par un flic
qui était un peu sur les nerfs parce que
moi mon portable est tout le temps en
panne ça m'énerve bonjour vous avez été
flashé là-bas à 60 km
[Musique]
1 2 3
4 5
8 9 et 10 voilà je ne dépasserai pas la
vitesse d'accord je ne dépasserai pas la
vitesse je le jure je le jure merci
monsieur l'agent merci Monsieur allez
c'est bon
ça se fait pas ça mais si ça se fait pas
mais si ça sent mais si ça se fait
maintenant ça se fait peu importe j'ai
pas entendu la loi mais faites voir la
loi vous me faites voir le le l'arrêter
c'est vous l'arrêter
moi ça m'arrange pas moi ça m'arrange
pas non plus monsieur il faut que
j'aille chercher mes gosses j'ai besoin
d'une voiture
j'ai compris
[Musique]